il a fêté ses 80 ans l'an dernier avec
ses sept mille mètres carrés de tôle et
sa structure de type eiffel le hangar de
l'aérodrome de thise est unique en
france
classé monument historique en 2007 il
est aujourd'hui recouverts de rouille
[Musique]
le risque c'est que des tôles s'envole
encore de provence à fès en cas de neige
et c'est donc sur un frein dans
l'activité ce qui serait dommage pour
sauver cet édifice
le coût de la rénovation s'élève à 2,5
millions d'euros
état et collectivités devraient financer
ce projet qui pourrait être boostée par
une enveloppe supplémentaire de 300000
euros
si le site venait à être retenu parmi la
sélection finale de stéphane bern va
nous le tous les pilotes ça nous réjouit
parce que le hangar donne des signes de
fatigue pas tellement mécanique mais
quand il pleut bas nous avions sont
mouillés l'aérodrome de thise sera dans
quelques jours s'il est définitivement
sélectionné coup de pouce ou non les
travaux devraient avoir lieu cet été
ce qui n'empêche pas le maire d'espérer
on trouve dans la liste des des dossiers
qui ont été retenus des fontaines des
églises
enfin des lavoirs donc des sites que je
vais dire un peu classique et ce site
qui est un peu original à mon avis a
certainement ses chances d'être
sélectionné à la rentrée le site devrait
donc 4 flambant neuf un lifting
idéal pour faire décoller son activité
[Musique]